the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen-only mode
good morning everyone and welcome to
investor exposure or Maine may 7th my
name is Anna and I'll be your host today
we are having a great lineup of four
speakers for you
Michael ball toss for the first time on
our show Keith Harwood
Troy Noonan and dr. Barry burns this
session will be recorded and sent to
your email please take a look at your
GoToWebinar control panel into the
questions box you will be able to ask
any questions you want during the
speakers presentation I would like to
begin I'll bring to the show our first
guest
mic unmuted hi Michael hi Anna good
morning how are you good morning
perfect morning the viewer starts and
give the great speaker what are we going
to talk about today okay thank you today
I'm gonna be talking about you know what
I call hidden trading opportunities and
you know most traders say most traders
majority of traders strictly look at one
aspect of the market which is price but
there's other underlying things in the
market like volume that help you
determine you know really what's
happening in the market I want to show
you how you can use those different
pieces to find what I call hidden
trading opportunities that other traders
just don't see in the market because
they're not necessarily looking at that
information sounds good to me let's
rocket and okay good you can see my
screen okay yep okay wonderful
all right so hey everyone good morning
on this Thursday you know it's the
Thursday before Mother's Day and you
know it's really starting to feel like
spring and you know the summer's coming
up so you know it's a good time to you
know really jump into the markets you
know before we would always think well
school is going to be ending soon and
I'm going to be spending a lot of time
with kids but now we sort of have this
new normal where the kids are at home
and we're trying to juggle you know work
and school and you know everything else
that goes on in the house at the same
time and you know it's it's a great time
to
expand your knowledge on the markets
right because you know we're at home
can't really go out anywhere it's
unfortunate the price of gas and oil is
so low that you can't really travel
anywhere so it's a great time to catch
up on your education of the market so
today I'll be talking about uncovering
hidden trading opportunities with order
flow and what I'm going to show you is
you know hidden trading opportunities
that other traders miss how to use those
hidden trading opportunities to get an
edge over other traders and how to use
it with order flow you're going to find
these with order flow and it's gonna be
very quick and to the point for those
that are new to my presentation my name
is Michael Altos and you know I've been
in the market since the early 90s and
you know just a brief background on
myself you know I started at the lowest
level in the industry I started as a
runner with Dean Witter Reynolds back on
the CMA floor and eventually you know
over after about two years I realized
you know electronic trading was really
starting to take off how can I get into
you know the electronic trading aspect
of it and I had the opportunity to join
the Glo what they called the Globex
trading desk at Dean Witter Reynolds
which is basically you know all the
electronic exchanges at the time seemed
he had Globex CBOT he had project a
Comex nymex had access then also at the
same time because those markets were
only open during the overnight session I
also had access to all the rest of the
world's exchanges you know your ex life
well it was DTB back then not your ex
the asian exchanges SIMEX tokyo and you
know it was really an eye-opening
experience for me after that after about
three years I left there and I joined
ETF man to be English trading company on
their global macro desk again to trade
all sorts of commodities then I was
hired by Commerce Bank to be their your
ex trader based in Chicago right so I
traded everything that was on the Eurex
against the US product so German buns
against the US ten years Bobble against
the five years dax against the NASDAQ
and emini then after that I joined
Cargill the big American trading company
and I spent four years there I was
training desk manager they sent me
Singapore to set up a trading desk even
after about two years in Chicago so
after that I joined JPMorgan I spent
eight years as vice president of Futures
Trading and it was a trading job right
it wasn't where I was just sitting on a
corner office looking at spreadsheets
come on and say hey you know what you
you're trading too much etc calm it down
no you know banging away at the keyboard
keyboard monkey for eight years
basically but after that you know I got
tired I was in my early 40s and I said
you know there's got to be more to life
than just working 12 hours a day and so
I left JPMorgan that's a nice job and
you know spend more time with my family
but you know after about a year I I got
itchy and wanted to get back into the
markets you know I was trading for
myself during that time and I was using
an order flow software which was okay
but you know I realized that software
can do a lot more than just plot a chart
right so in 2015 I created the order
flows trader producers for ninja trader
8 it's a volume footprint chart right
but what I did is I took my forms of
order flow analysis and I put it into
the chart so the order flows trader as
it has evolved over the last five years
now has seven pre-programmed order flow
indicators and the charge that I use in
this presentation are generated with
order flow trader software and the neat
thing is you know let the computer do
the work for you right this is 2020 okay
this is not 1998 where you know you're
just happy to have a plain chart you
know the computer can do a lot of the
analysis for you and you know what's
nice about the order flow trader or
software the volume footprint chart or
any volume footprint chart for that
matter is it takes all the information
that's generated by the exchange you
know the volume traded on the bid the
volume traded on the offer and puts it
into a nice easy to read format so that
analysis can be performed on it excuse
me now yeah in around
2015 2014 2015 I started writing my book
on order flow right I wanted to give a
contribution to the trading society so I
wrote this book called trading order
flow and it's a hundred fifty page book
if you stick around to the end I'm gonna
give it to you for free I wanna show you
how to download it for free off my
website so before I jump in your brief
disclaimer basically only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those with sufficient risk capital
should consider trading past before it's
not necessarily indicative of future
results now I got to go through a couple
basics you know cuz you can never stress
the basics enough right whether it's
basketball or trading and with order
flow you have to start with three what I
call three building blocks right because
all of the rest of order flow analysis
stems from one of these three or a
combination of all of these three and
it's Delta point of control and
imbalances right it's like having
different little blocks but when you put
them together you know you could build
something you could build a trading plan
around it so just really briefly Delta
is the difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers in a bar
and it's important so you know who is
dominating the bar now every bar has a
delta and most software mine for example
puts it along the bottom of the chart
there's also internal Delta's I'm not
gonna get into Delta today but this is
one of the building blocks from which
you can build a trading plan to trade
the market now the second thing is point
of control and point of control in the
bar is the price level with the most
volume and what's beautiful about it is
there's no fancy mathematical formula to
determine it other than simple
arithmetic you take all the volume
traded on the bid side all the volume
traded on the offer side and that's your
point of control for the bar every bar
has one you know I have just a few
arrows here but every bar has one you
see the rectangle around the bar and
what that tells you is that tells you
the area where the most volumes traded
in the bar and you could sort of take it
a step further and once you realize
that's the area where most trading
occurred in the bar that in the loose
sense is your value area for that bar
now
the third piece is imbalances a market
imbalance occurs when there are more
aggressive buyers than sellers or
vice-versa
more aggressive sellers than buyers in
the two-way auction right remember the
market is bid and it's offered its
twenty eight twenty seven and a quarter
bid at twenty eight twenty seven and a
half so that's the two-way auction and
in buying a balance occurs when there's
at least four times as many traders
buying the offer then traders selling
the bid and conversely a selling
imbalance occurs when there is at least
four times as many traders selling the
bid then find the offer now I say four
times that's sort of a guideline right
there's some people that use ten times
as much some people that use three times
as much sort of the industry standard is
four to one and think of it like this
all right you have a seesaw well the
side that's more heavier in this case
more aggressive is the side that's going
to win so how it looks on an order flow
chart is in the volume footprint all
right you have red numbers you have blue
numbers you have black numbers black
numbers is your normal trading that is
occurring a red number is going to be
your selling imbalance that's gonna
appear on the bid side a blue number in
the bar is a buying a balance it's
telling you there's more aggressive
buyers at that price level in the
two-way auction okay so why is that
matter is because generally as a market
Rises you see buying imbalances my
ggressive buyers are lifting the best
offer and looking for the next best
offer demand is present all right think
of that buying imbalance is generally
equate to demand now when a market Falls
you see selling imbalances aggressive
sellers are selling into the best bid
and looking for the next best bid to
sell into in this case supply is present
all right so now that you have those
basics right let's jump into the other
hidden trading opportunities that you
know can really transform your trading
now you know traders when they're new to
the markets they always stumble across
things like this right the candlestick
cheat sheet
if only trading was this easy uh well
you have this pattern you buy you have
this pattern you sell right what they
don't really talk about sometimes is you
know they don't talk about context you
know in context often comes into you
know market structure as well as volume
so you know I'm gonna show you
you know I pulled examples from
yesterday right to show you that these
opportunities appear daily all right I'm
not going through weeks and weeks of
charts to pull out you know the one
picture-perfect one this is all
yesterday this is all emini x' is all
one minute charts you know be consistent
you know sometimes I do presentations
and I show people you know a one-minute
chart a five-minute chart a thousand
tick range of 5,000 volume and then
people get confused I go my gosh I have
so many charts no I do that to show you
that the same concepts apply on
different charts but for today's
purposes I'm going to keep it uniform
one minute charts a minis just so you
can see that you know how often these
appear okay so here you got a nice
bullish candlestick pattern right the
market should rally based off your your
handy-dandy
you know Candlestick cheat sheet right
so you you gonna be looking to buy are
you expecting the market to go up well
what happens it didn't go as expected
right the market sold off you know 20
points basically and you you you the
part of order flow that really stands
out is understanding what's happening in
the market and you can see right this
red candle right here with the arrows
pointing down to is what gave it away
now if you're looking at a normal bar
chart you can't really tell by the time
you get to the big red candle and you're
stopped out yeah it's obvious that this
market isn't going up but at this point
it's too late already already stopped
out you already took your loss but if
you had bought off of this bullish
candle pattern
time you get to this red bar by the time
it closes you should really be looking
to get out now before this big down
candle happens and stops you out if
you're a long and that's where the
beauty of order flow comes in and what
do we see in this red candle here right
the blue box I drew there this pink box
around this bar is telling me two things
one I can see there's a stack sound and
balance in here you see this red zone
here you see 11 against 1659 against 3-1
61 against 16 you have three selling
imbalances stacked neatly on top of each
other it's called a stacks on a balance
now the order flows trader software will
put a pink box around any bar that has
three or more imbalances whether they're
stacked or not as you can see there's a
pink box here there's three leather
stack buying a balance of three and then
there's another buying imbalance here
and you can see down here right off the
low all right you see one two three
buying imbalances in there that's how
you can use software to take the
information that you're seeing in the
market and go deeper into it all right
take that information okay well yeah
there's a lot of bids and offers in here
but what does it mean well when you
start putting it together well I've got
one two three buying balances right off
the load of this move do you think
that's bullish or bearish well it's most
likely bullish right you can see all the
marketers rallied up a little bit
alright so sometimes trying to figure
out which way
a trade is going is like this you know
trying to figure out which wire to to
fix right it's confusing because
oftentimes you get a lot of different
potential trading opportunities so for
example right candlestick patterns
basically would you buy here well yeah
you got a bullish marubuzo candle
pattern right so you should be buying
her all right well it doesn't work okay
so you got another pattern at a new low
well you got a doji candle pattern or
inning top some people will argue right
okay well yeah that's potentially
bullish okay well you know you try to
buy that you get stopped out okay then
you get down here you get to this new
swing low well is it it's not really a
candle pattern you know I spent 20
minutes last night going through a lot
of my candlestick books see if I could
find this pattern it's not really a
pattern okay
closest I can find is an inverted
umbrella you know these chanting Chinese
candlesticks got all these wonderful
names you know like three white soldiers
black crows etc you know there's there's
a bit of romance tied to them but you
know when they work fantastic but
oftentimes they don't work you know
there's been studies and I could get
into it but there's been a lot of
studies on different candlestick
patterns and you know to find the best
ones work about 65% of the time but even
that you know out of a month you
probably get three trades or something
like that four trades you know so it's
not very practical in that sense all
right so if you got three choices all
right you got a B and C all right a
started to work out a little bit you
know went up a little bit B nah you know
just went up and me they came down and
see well you know they're all basically
bullish patterns but it's C is the one
that caused you know the nice reversal
from basically 2850 all the way up to 28
75 but you know what was there in the
order flow right now point a you know
it's a trade I like to take you know
honestly
we've got three buying imbalances in the
bar you know the market did rally up
about four points before turn around and
it's starting to come down you know this
is one that you know you could have
taken a small loss or broken even on
okay fine
you know those trades happen be never
right there's nothing in the order flow
that's really outstandingly bullish see
we have what's called an imbalance
reversal okay you see this green arrow
pointing up here this is the beauty of
the software's it does the analysis for
you tells you there's an imbalance
reversal now people are gonna ask well
Michael what's an imbalance reversal
okay well imbalance reversals occur when
traders are trapped in a market right
there long and wrong they're short in
the hole the two expressions people like
to throw around ask yourself how many
times have you sold the low of a move or
got long at the high and you were
trapped I think about it right markets
coming down you finally say ah smart guy
I've been buying a I bought B the market
is turning around making new lows sell
it alright then you sell down here it's
the low the move market starts creeping
back up you know you're kicking yourself
you turn off your machine I'm I'm an
idiot I'm not trading anymore that's an
imbalance reversal you're basically you
sold a low the move you got long at a
high you're trapped now the beauty of
the software right you could have the
software do this analysis for you so you
don't have to sit there and split hairs
is this a reversal is this not you know
what's the point of having a footprint
chart if it's not helping you analyze
the order flow right there's so many
footprint shots out there there's just a
plain footprint chart there's so much
information that's coming through in the
order flow let the computer software
analyze it for you and tell you
something is happening and again you
know this is just yesterday I'll give
you a couple more examples here's an
imbalance reversal a bearish one right
this red arrow right here all right you
can see the market again had a nice
sell-off from you know the 6870 area
down below sixty okay again this is all
on emini one-minute chart here
the market that's moving higher right
you got your imbalance reversal here in
this bar this blue box here well I drew
the box to highlight it it's this little
green arrow here and you see as the
market continued to higher from 64 all
the way up above you know 69 70 I can on
one minute emini charts from yesterday
traders see what they want to see not
what's actually there you know ice plays
trick I say the eye plays tricks on you
because often times you know we have a
bias we come into the market we have a
bias and there's times like this where
you sort of get conflicting signals okay
you have a double top you got a pin bar
in the middle here which is bullish
right you got these long wicks under
these bars which is bullish this double
top is bearish what do you do you could
sit out you know you get long do you get
short you're gonna be asking okay this
markets been trending up are we pausing
here just as we paused earlier but then
we're gonna make a new move higher or is
the market getting ready for a reversal
the other traders will say you got to
wait for confirmation well why wait all
right look at what's happening in the
order flow to tell you potentially which
way the markets gonna go if you look at
the order flow it becomes a lot clearer
it's pretty bearish okay you have two
points a and point B point a of multiple
selling imbalances in the bar they're
not stacked so you don't see stacks on a
balance in the bar but instead you see
one two three imbalances 156 against
thirty seven thirty three against three
ninety five against seven okay now point
B you know again we just turn around you
know go sideways here we have what's
called a prominent point of control
right remember every bar has a point of
control but there's gonna be some points
to control which matter right and that's
what the software analyzes for you it's
gonna tell you that hey you know what
this point of control is bearish right
so you put it together with the multiple
selling balances here obviously you got
the negative deltas as well
and the market sells off right it sells
off from 65 down to 60 where you got a
bullish prominent point of control okay
but you know if you're waiting for
confirmation oh you know I want to break
this the bottom of this bar here well
you just gave up you know a point and a
half you know six ticks of potential
profit by getting in here later all
right you say well you know you know
maybe we'll break a draw a trendline
here you're still not getting in any
better if you even if you draw a
trendline up from this bottom this
bottom you're still getting short around
you know the 64 area the areas you
should be getting short in is you know
65 and above
and again let the software do the hard
work for you right you could sure you
could look at an order flow chart of
volume footprint chart and see yeah I
got some three and silent imbalances in
here you know maybe you can try and
figure out you know the the concept of a
prominent point of control and say yeah
this point of control matters you know
but why not just let the software do it
for you make your life easy all right on
the order flow straighter you know the
software we have the setting right here
multiple imbalances occur when there are
three or more buying or selling
imbalances in a bar going to draw this
violet box around it tells you that
they're aggressive buyers are clearly in
control right now or aggressive sellers
are in control now POC trader is what's
going to tell you about prominent points
of control again it's hard coded right
in there right you could adjust the
settings you can change the colors
whatever you like
remember every bar has a point of
control but not every bar has a point of
control that matters prominent point of
control is a point of control that's
going to act as support or resistance
you know if it's a bullish prominent
point of control it's going to tell you
that's support if it's bearish primary
point of control that's resistance let
the software do that work for you right
this is the normal candlestick chart you
can't see market imbalances alright you
can't see where prominent points of
control acting as support or resistance
are coming in but if you're looking at a
volume footprint chart
you can get software that helps do that
analysis so you can see yeah I've got
aggressive sellers here in this bar
I've got resistance in this bar yeah
you've got you're at a swing high you've
got aggressive sellers coming in you got
signs of resistance where do you think
the markets gonna go it's not gonna go
higher chances are it's gonna go lower
right and the beauty is you know that
what you're seeing here right with the
resistance with the aggressive sellers
it's gonna allow you to keep your stop
relatively close you know just above the
high of this level right so you could be
getting short here rather than later and
down here right you're gonna find
yourself with much better entries you
know better entries equal better profits
now the other beauty of order flow is
its going to show you areas where the
market is coming into where support or
resistance is present right don't end up
like this guy
right there's no support present you
know you want to be like the guy that
can hold the weight right and think of
the market the same way you know you
have supply which is selling pressure
you have demand which is buying pressure
sometimes it's just too much it's gonna
overwhelm the market what you want to do
is you want to find those areas where
there's that support is present where
you can see it coming in now again
yesterday just before the 11:00 o'clock
you know he came down into this low down
here at 53 then we started rallying up a
bit into the you know little 60s but
then we're holding this area around you
know 55 and a half all right in here
right we keep coming down and test it
rally up come down rally up come down
then we start rolling up and then
obviously we rally all the way up from
you know the 60 area into you know
another five six handles
okay but what's what's so special about
this area you know anything well people
say well you got a low here you blah
blah blah etc well why not think you
know look at the order flow now the POC
is the clue but honestly right now it's
not so clear okay cuz yeah you've got
you know you've got a bullish primary
point of control here you got another
low point of control here you got a
couple sort of around the same level
but did you know you could actually see
up to three points of control levels in
a bar so you're not just gonna know the
point of control level with the most
volume you can also know where the level
with the second most volume and the
third most volume oftentimes it's spread
out it's distributed among a bar but
when you have start seeing groups of
bars where they're all sort of clustered
together here here here here here you
know their support in the market you
know and you know people that use a heat
map write a book whether it's book map
or a ninja traders heat map or jigsaws I
think there's called heat map also you
know you would see like these orders
filling in down here you know bright
orange colors etc to act you know oh
yeah support there but if you're just
watching the order flow you see well
yeah it actually traded decent volume
here it held decent volume here at held
decent volume here how decent volume
here and how decent volume here at hell
and this is all around that fifty five
and a half two fifty six in the quarter
area so you know that there's some very
strong support here and as the market
finally popped up where would you know
think about it if you know there support
coming in here right you buy in here
fifty-seven fifty-eight you have a stop
just below this area in here you know
fifty five fifty five and a half so
you've got a very tight stop right
you're getting long around you know
fifty-seven fifty-eight with a stop
around fifty five and a half so you can
see clearly where there is strong
support or resistance at a level and
again the beauty is let the software do
it for you right you can see here on the
order flow straighter software you could
set up to three points of controls right
the main point of control point of
control number two point of control
number three now you could even you know
I have in this case I have two and three
set to transparent but you know I'd set
it to gray if I want to see the other
two or you could get even more creative
with the colors you know you could have
you can set it to in this case I put it
to green for the strongest yellow for
the second red for
the third okay and I can get into it but
the other reason there's a reason for
that
just think of red yellow green right
traffic lights you know red yellow green
boom and look for the market to to rally
you know red yellow green yeah you you a
lot with order flow is pattern
recognition now what makes wonderful
analysis so extremely powerful and
useful is that it shows you areas where
the market can back up to and hold
before continuing on in its original
direction for another 10-15 ticks or
more order flow show use shows you those
levels okay there's another example
yesterday this is around 2:00 in the
afternoon quarter after 2:00 2:15
Chicago time y'all mark is just going
sideways sorry if you remember that
we're just sort of trading you know
between 65 and and 58 right yeah this
sort of snaking y'all going sideways
people can say well you know we got you
know got swing low then you know your
high and high or low the other people
say well you know we got the low got the
lower high let's address okay you can go
either way at this point all right but
honestly looking at an order flow chart
yeah yeah it's kind of mixed right you
have bullish signs and you have bearish
signs okay
that's we're adding the second or third
point of control is going to help you
right when you analyze the second and
third point of control it really stands
out what you're seeing in the market and
what you're looking for are sort of
these clusters right you know three or
three bars or more with point control
sort of grouped around the same area
alright so think about here you have
three bars right three bars each bar has
three points of control you know the the
most second most of the third most
levels so that's nine levels over three
bars right you'll see one you'll see two
PLC three if you're looking at basically
price area the zone so to speak where
you have you know seven out of nine
points of controls lined up that's
important information okay so you have
it right here alright these three bars
are then here you've got also seven out
of nine here you got eight out of nine
so what do I see I see this group of
volume here alright I see another lower
group of volume coming in here I see
another group of volume coming in here
and once that tanya is you know traders
are happy to start trading you know
their size at lower levels all right so
it's migrating lower the market is sort
of migrating lower where people are
happy to start selling some more buyers
are happy to start buying a little bit
lower try and buy lower just tell me
there's a lot of supply when you see
points of controls migrating down
telling you supply as present in the
market and again on a bar chart you're
not gonna see that and on this
candlestick chart alright you're not
gonna see this area in here you're not
gonna see this area in here it just
looks like this market is kind of mixed
kind of going sideways nothing nothing
really but look at the move that
happened right after that you know from
fifty eight down into the into the 40s
right and the beauty is you know where
you can be placing your stop right above
these little volume clusters right these
groups of points of control all right
stop
we put your stop there if you're getting
short after these this group of point of
control your stops just right here if
you're getting short off of the second
box your stops just right up here off
the third one your stops just right up
here you know you're trailing your stop
right behind and the beauty is it's
right before the market breaks right
before you start seeing all the
aggressive selling coming in right
because what's happening the value is
slowly migrating lower now if you're
looking at a volume profile say on the
side yeah it's gonna be hard to detect
that but you can manage it on a smaller
scale right here right right before this
market breaks down you could have gotten
the signs that a you know what we're
starting to migrate lower in value
so yeah aspects of order flow analysis
such as point of control Delta
imbalances are very useful for assessing
market action right for identifying and
evaluating training opportunities but
you know the most important part you
know a vetting order flow to your
trading arsenal is finding trades that
the public misses right that's the whole
power of order flow right that's how you
get the most out of order flow now you
know I said earlier you know I'm just
gonna show you charts on on a one-minute
chart I wanted to show you this on a
1-minute chart but it was much clearer
around a five-minute chart this is the
emails from yesterday now if you
remember right the cash open you know
going into the cash open we rallied up
from this 66 area all the way up into
the 80s excuse me
and we put these two bars here you know
price action traders all you know you
got your got your two pin bars there you
got this double top but why okay it's
nice to look after the fact that say
yeah you know after this market sold off
and you say well yeah you know you've
gotten your - you know here - pin bars
here but if this market rallied up
they'd say well you had your two pin
bars right here right so you should have
bought you know you had two pin bars
essentially right here the market didn't
sell off right you could go through all
these things you know and find a lot of
patterns that didn't work right but what
makes this level so special you know why
did it come back here why didn't it come
back up here test this this earlier high
up here or this high over here why this
level we know why in here okay people
say well you have this resistance that
became support you know you can pull out
all sorts of things out of your mind
that you know well after the fact but if
you're looking at the order flow all
right this is what it looked like here
all right those two bars on the orthos
the 8:30 are and 8:35 bar right right
after the cash open came right up here
between 80 and a quarter and eight
1 and 3/4 then stopped and dropped like
a rock you know 50 points well you go
back whoops wrong chart you have this
cluster right here look at this you got
1 2 3 4 5 6 bars where the points of
controls are essentially the same level
you know you got one up here you got one
below it but you got six bars you got 3
6 12 15 16 17 18 19 out of
you know how many potential bars all
these points controls 12 13 14 15 16 out
of potential 18 points of control all at
that same level and this is a period
over from 610 to 635 it's you know
essentially 30 minutes where you're
putting in a lot of value here right so
it's not strange to see the market come
back right up to that level right came
right up here came right to this level
right didn't come up to this level up
here didn't come up to this level or you
know any other level it came right to
this level because this little group of
bars it showed strong resistance with
the POC clustered together and again if
you're looking at this bar chart you're
not gonna know you just got this little
sideways action now nothing special but
in the order flow all right you can see
excuse me that's where the volume was
people say well you got these low volume
bars well you know at this time of the
day you know it's average volume
why isn't the market going any higher
every time it tries to go higher sellers
coming in so buyers a back and forth
right it's a two-way struggle in the
market right between buyers and sellers
everyone is happy to transact at this
level right in here that's why the
market came back to this level not this
upper level not a lower level came back
here because it was met with that same
resistance that was here earlier right
well this market had been going up came
off a little bit you know if you could
have gone back up but why not all right
there were sellers in here so when the
market got back up to this level it was
met with sellers again and then the
market dropped you know 30 points from
that area right after the cash open so
you know hopefully by now you can see
how order flow analysis provides the
trader
you know the kind of advanced
information that they need to gain the
edge over other traders right that's
what you want right you want an edge
over the people you're trading against
and how do you get an edge is you find
things in the market that other traders
aren't seeing that's where order flow
comes in because it allows you to see
what's happening underneath the market
you know people say see inside the bar I
like to think of it as you know it's
like when you pull up a rock right you
know you got a rock sitting out in the
yard you pull it up and then you see a
lot of bugs and worms underneath that's
what the order flow is all right tell
you about this whole ecosystem happening
under underneath the bar that you see
right in front of you so hopefully you
can see how powerful order flow analysis
is you know there's no need to
overcomplicate trading trade what's
happening right in front of you right so
if you found this helpful
you'll really like the order flow trader
software package that I have which makes
order flow analysis easy so let me ask
you know who wants to make order flow
analysis part of their training now
there's two ways right you could do this
on your own you spend a year two years
looking at a screen trying to figure out
order flow I know people that have spent
years literally you know since the mid
to 20 you know 2013 2014 looking at
order flow even to this day still
haven't really figured it out and more
importantly can we sell out
money right by putting it in training
accounts think you figured it out and
after a few days realized after you lost
25% 30% of your account realize you
don't know what the [__] you're doing
then don't go that route alright take
the easy route get the education in
software it's made by a trader who has
used order flow at the highest level for
decades right I said I've been trading
at an institutional level right I don't
tell you about my background to brag or
not I want you to know where I'm coming
from where I learned this all this you
know how to put these pieces together
you know and more important you want to
skip the wasted time skip the trading
losses you know you get the order flows
trader software
it runs on ninjatrader 8 it's not
available for TOS is not available for
trade of 8 it's not available for
TradeStation it runs on ninja trader and
yes it will run on the free version of
ninja trader and it's the volume
footprint chart with 7 pre-programmed
order flow indicators you know later
this summer we're going to do another
release we've got another I've got at
least four other indicators that were
putting into the order flows trader
software yeah ok also more importantly
you get my chart template and we'll show
you if you know you have trouble
installing the chart template I'm going
to show you I even got a quick video to
show you how to create your own chart
template and you know it bothers me you
know cuz i used to use different order
flow software years ago before i came
out with my own and it was so
frustrating because the so darn
complicated alright and trying to yeah
they were you know I'm a pretty
resourceful person I could sort of
figure things out but I need you know
some direction where do I go how do I
change this chart to look like this
because you'd see these guys with their
software a nice beautiful chart I can
never get my chart to look like that
so you get my chart template so your
chart can look just like mine and you
can modify it from there
normally I offer this for $8.99 alright
but you're not gonna pay anywhere near
that today you know but I realize having
order flow software is one thing right
the next thing is you have to know how
to use it
don't just give you the software and
send you on your own way I provide a lot
of education on how to trade with order
flow you know I have a course write the
order flow trading course is 15 hours of
video instruction you know when I
created this course I wanted something
that could be done in a on a Saturday
afternoon but when I started recording I
realized it's probably gonna be a
weekend course not a not a one day
course okay but this really takes you
through the basics of order flow right
but I realize you know most people at
this stage really have a firm
understanding of the basics of order
flow so they want something more
advanced so I give you access to my
order flow inner circle video series is
56 videos on advanced order flows tricks
tips of analysis you'll normally sell it
access to this course for just about
$500 I'm gonna throw it in as well with
the software so you know software
wonderful training course the inner
circle you know you normally cost 1693
1693 but again I don't want you to pay
that much you know we're in a time of a
lot of people don't know you know if
they're gonna have a job in six months
or anything like that so I'm gonna throw
it you know we're spending at home a lot
at home a lot of time I'm gonna give you
my favorite course that I created my
order flow playbook which normally sell
for 297 again I'm gonna give it to you
for free so you got a lot of educational
material right because I don't want you
to fail I don't want you to get you know
get involved in order flow and give it
up and in a week or two no I you know I
want you to understand what you're
seeing in the market that's why I give a
lot of educational material because you
know you gotta know what you're looking
at and you're not gonna know unless
somebody takes you by the hand and shows
you now you know what other people are
saying you know Sheila says you know
your order flows trader software is
remarkably helpful I can clearly see now
what's happening in the market like for
example who's in control of the market
on a very specific time and who's
getting weaker as well
you know and you know other comments you
know from social media you know if you
really want to trade properly to
understand what on earth is happening
the market order flow is the path
forward it Mike's experience and
explanations make it click so you got to
realize right
if you want to be a successful trader
you got to go out there and get it it's
not gonna fall in your lap it's not
gonna just one day automatically click
in your head you're gonna understand I
should buy here and sell here no all
right you got to get trained so you know
if you're interested it's a one-time
payment 675 there's no monthly payments
no other payments in the future you do
need to pay your data fees and
ninjatrader fees you know you're you
that that's you know just part of
trading but the software that I have
runs on ninja traders you can run on the
free version as well as the paid version
and it's just a one-time payment of 675
so what you do is you go to this page
down here at the bottom order flows comm
/o f2 o ft 2 dot HTML takes you to this
page you see the linker right up here
order flows comm / off to scroll down to
the bottom of the page the others
there's some instructional videos there
for you to watch you can see here right
one-time payment 675 what else so you
get access to you just click that button
I want this takes you to PayPal PayPal
processes your payment I don't get your
credit card information I don't want it
so if you stuck around and you want to
get a copy of my book go to this page
order flows comm slash book HTML there's
a little area in here you have to enter
your name first name last name and email
and click Submit after that it will take
you to a page with the book that's in
the PDF form you can just download it to
your computer print it whatever it's 150
pages you know I want you to enjoy it so
you know go you know part of life is
about taking action right yet you have
to get off your butt and and you know
actually do something so again you know
go to order flows calm / off to HTML
to that page you know to get started you
know the most important thing I could
tell you is you got to get started right
you got to do something otherwise it's
gonna be a year later from now and you
gonna say oh my gosh I should have got
started last year you know they always
say you know when's the best time to
plant the tree was 20 years ago and
second best time is yesterday is right
now so you know look at yourself you
know I I know I when this lockdown
started yeah stay locked on this stay at
home order in Illinois I live in
Illinois when that started I had a big
list of things I wanted to do I've only
gotten through maybe about a third of my
list of things but I realized you know
if I don't put this stuff down on things
that I want to do now while you know
we're they stuck at home but while we're
at home I'll probably never get around
to doing it so and the same thing is
about trading and learning to be a
better trader you got to start now right
now is the best time to start VIX is
coming down vixx's in today's in the low
30s you know if we get VIX down into you
know a more manageable 20 you know 15 to
25 area I think the markets will be real
really calm down markets are really
starting to calm down also it's a great
time to get involved in the markets so
anyway Anna I don't have time for
questions but you know I'm gonna throw
it back to you hopefully I answered
everybody's question and thanks for
having me today thanks so much Michael
you're welcome let's move on
to show our next presenter Keith Harwood
hi kid I am a muted by having me it's
good it's great having you people on the
show what are you planning to share with
us today yeah so I've got a a good
PowerPoint I think talking about swing
trading in this current market
environment and I think it's you know
sort of a appropriate topic given that
way I think we've got kind of a unique
market relative to what we've had in the
past obviously so let me pull that up
I'll pull up my screen here all right
all right can you see the presentation
okay
yes cream looks good to me I will good
but I just made you an organizer that
you would be able to see all the
questions from the attendees during your
presentation and I will get back to you
around 9:30 Pacific excellent yeah so
thanks again for having me I might in
Keith Harwood I'd like to focus on swing
trading when we've got market conditions
like this so that's what I wanted to
talk about everybody with today
particularly with an option